there are
a lot of denominations that keep the
sabbath what is the identifying mark
that confirms that
seventh-day adventist or seven-day
adventism is god's remnant church
very good question revelation 12 17
and the dragon was rocked let me pray
again father this is a very important
question
give me the right words dear god please
in jesus name
amen and the dragon was wrath with the
woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
a seed which keep the commandments of
god and have the testimony of jesus
christ
that is an identify mark of the remnant
church the testimony of jesus christ
which is the spirit of prophecy
according to revelation 19 verse 10
and you compare that with uh chapter 22
verse 9.
the testimony of the presence of the
prophetic voice in that church
is one of the identifying marks i'll
tell you something else that's an
identifying mark listen to jesus matthew
18-20 and jesus came and spake unto them
saying
all power is given unto me in heaven and
earth go ye
therefore and teach all nations
christ sent the disciples to all nations
so if we combine those identifying marks
the observance of the ten commandments
including the fourth the presence of the
prophetic
voice among that people and the presence
of that people
all over the world if you belong to a
church
a denomination that's only found in new
york and connecticut
how can that be god's remnant church
where it is not found
all over the world and one of the marks
of god's church
is they will go to all nations
by the way i may be digressing the only
two churches on the face of the earth
that come close to satisfying that
identifying mark
that's the seventh after this church and
the catholic church there are in more
nations
more countries than any other nation you
look at the two
now the catholic church may say and i'm
not picking on people i'm just looking
at the nominations well
we are we're in so many nations yes
let's look at another qualifying mark
do you observe the commandments of god
and the answer is no
and you have to have all the marks not
just one
the commandments of god to prophet your
voice in the church you must be in
all parts of the world you must have the
faith of jesus as well
and so we look for all not just one so
there's a church
observing saturday in the sense that
they don't work
but do they see sabbath as the mark and
the seal of god
do they see the sabbath as the center of
god's law do they see the sabbath as the
commandment that
identified god's reign the universe
his title his right to rule do they see
the
sabbath as that as the highest of the
ten commandments
how do they see the sabbath is this
simply a day to avoid work
but my main point is the church must
have all the identified marks not just
one
and by the way everyone who genuinely
keeps established
will have no problem with the other
march accepting the other marks
as they are presented because the
sabbath commandment
is the test commandment it was for the
israelites in the wilderness
it will be for god's people in the last
days it's the test commandment
anyone who genuinely keeps the sabbath
will do whatever else god says
amen amen now other skeet you have to
let me know when to stop because
keep rolling in okay all right
so someone has asked and
i'm okay i'll ask this question first
many meetings occur
after the service on sabbath for example
planning for a pathfinder event or
planning for
women's ministry event is this okay
god is a good god since the nation all
those listening
god is so good let me give you three
examples of how good god is he made
seven days he gave us six
are you following me he said you take
six and do all you need to do i'll take
one that's mine
god says here's a hundred dollars you
keep 90 10 belong to me
god says here all the trees on the face
of the earth
i reserve only one you keep all the rest
now that's a good god god could have
taken the reverse
position and told adam only one tree is
available to you
all the others are mine that would have
been difficult for adam
why am i saying that god has given us
six days to do all that we have to do
that does not belong on the sabbath why
do we try to cram
everything on the seventh day of the
holy day
one of the reasons is we are not willing
to give god some time during the week
we just barely give him the sabbath day
but we are not willing to give god time
during the week
we act as if our lives during the week
are is ours
now our lives are ours but they're not
the god of the sabbath
is also the god of the entire week it is
he that preserves life
we must be willing to give god some time
during the week the same way a tithe has
an offering
the sabbath is specified there's no
argument there how much time will i give
god during the week
we can have our meetings on different
days people ask me well
can i have sex on the sabbath you have
six days
can i do this on the sabbath you have
why pile everything on god's holy day
it is because i suspect we do not
appreciate the holiness of the day
which then takes us one step further
back to the holiness
of the god of the sabbath leave
the sabbath alone it is one day
you have six the sabbath pushes us to
practice
time management so it is not
contaminated
by these events that more properly
belong during the week
leave god's day alone do all you have to
do listen to the commander
six days shall thou labor and do all thy
work all the secular
activities choir practice practicing
marching by the
pathfinders and the busy bees and
whomever do all of that in
six days leave my day
alone says god that's my response to
that
thank you thank you this next question
is
uh this week's sabbat school's lesson
touched on social kindness
uh doing acts of service on the sabbath
what is your response
uh to that um oh let me just read the
last phrase what is your response
uh to that if doing an act of service on
the sabbath
leads to making a purchase oh god frown
upon that
yeah the bible says jesus christ
jesus is lawful to do good on the
sabbath he never said it's lawful to
work
it's lawful to do good now disobedience
can never uh um what looks like a need
can never justify disobedience
because we're serving a god who's
capable of miraculous acts miraculous
acts let's remember that
disobedience can never be justified as
the basis for a good work on the sabbath
we serve a god who can work
miraculously we really do
when the ark was traveling on an ox cart
and it stumbled the cart stumbled azza
reached out to steady the ark god had
said
don't touch the ark
others intentions were good he wanted to
save the ark from falling and pressured
onto the ground
and god struck him dead not because god
is harsh but because god does not joke
when god says keep it holy he means
keep it holy and so i'm giving you the
principle on the basis of that principle
you can decide what kind of good social
cause you will pursue on the sabbath day
we are to keep the day holy we are to
avoid
secular activities on god's day we must
keep in mind
if some crisis arises god is a god of
miracles and god can intervene because
god
always honors obedience a genuine
sabbath keeper
looks for reasons to keep the sabbath
holy not for
reasons to compromise the holiness of
the day
but jesus said it is lawful to do good
if your animal falls into the pit of the
sabbath
pull it out if a man falls in pull it
out
you're driving to church in the winter
someone's in the ditch help the person
but thank you for this principle is it's
lawful to do good
it is not lawful to work by engaging
sexual activities
amen now this next question and i said i
will ask it because this is a youth that
has asked this question
all right how was god created
how was god created i know the question
uh you can answer how was god created
god was not created god has always been
god is the source of life
i am the way the truth and the life
jesus said
you will not come to me you may have
life god himself
everything flows from god as a matter of
fact if you read isaiah 9
verse 6 one of the names of jesus is the
everlasting father which means the
father of
eternity eternity floor from god that's
a concept that gives us a good
concussion as we try to think about it
god was not created all things flow from
god
listen to colossians 1 16 for by him
were all things created
that are in heaven and that are in earth
visible and invisible
whether they be thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers
all things were created by him and for
him verse 17
and he is before all things and by him
all things consist
four times we have the expression all
things if you say god was created
who created him god is god you don't go
further back than god
we cannot explain that fully but god
will reveal to us when we get to the
other side
god has always been there everything
comes from him by the way
when i father son holy ghost they were
not created
they've always been there and i'm glad
amen amen this question is how do we
know that the bible is the truth of god
because the bible's predictions are
absolutely reliable for a small example
daniel chapter 7. daniel chapter 7
predicted events
that occurred precisely as predicted in
the book of daniel daniel 2 and daniel 7
which is the the flaw of of nations
the babylonians in the time the book was
written the middle persians
the greeks and the romans and the
breaking of the roman empire into what
is now europe
as it was predicted in daniel 7 and
daniel 2
so it came to pass that's a simple but a
profound example
of the absolute reliability of the the
bible
you take the writings of luke and axe
luke was a medical doctor he was also a
historian
modern historians who studied book of
luke and axe
the books have looked at because the
same person wrote both they have
discovered
that all the persons all the places all
the events actually happen and occurred
the bible is an absolutely reliable book
when it deals with any subject it
chooses to touch on
but is history absolutely reliable
archaeology has repeatedly
confirmed the statements made in the
bible the events in the bible the
personalities in the bible
the bible is the most reliable book you
can read when read under the guidance
of the spirit of god there is no basis
for doubting the reliability of the
bible
let me say this there are no mistakes in
the bible not doctrinal mistakes
mistakes lie in the mind of the sinner
the bible as god's word has no doctrinal
mistakes
amen amen and elder skeet i'll notice
the last question
all right hello um
[Music]
hello hello uh do you have a question
yes uh and it goes back to
it before you there's no kindness
um i am
a contractor and um
i get up on a sabbath morning to go to
church
and uh one called me
to tell me my house i have
young children it's 18 degrees
um and i have no heat no hot water
on a situation like that how do you deal
with it do you tell them well
okay it's my sabbath i'll deal with that
after sabbath and
how do you deal with the situation like
that well we're dealing with a situation
that may lead to loss of life it's
winter there's no heat there's nothing
jesus said if your animal falls at the
pit the animal's life is a danger
pull it out if someone's about to help
the person you can't charge the person
because you're not to work in the sample
but it's an act of good it's a good work
that you're doing on that day
so it's not really work where you earn
money it is an act of mercy you're
performing
just like pulling an animal out of the
pit it's an act of mercy
someone says my heat is down i'm
freezing no hot water
little children you go you help it's a
good work
it's not a work that earns pay and if
you have to go to the store to purchase
material it's still okay now
that's where you have to talk to god
because there's a holy spirit who
directs and guides that's where you have
to talk to your god father should i take
this step of that step
is there another way to fix this problem
without taking an action that normally
would be a violation of the sabbath
you talk to god is there another way to
do this
so that i do not have to violate your
sabbath you put that to god the god will
direct you
okay thank you god bless you
thank you for that question now i'm
going to open the floor does anyone else
have a question that you would like to
pose
oh okay someone has yes i have a
question
go ahead my question is
um we assembly adventists have the six
days
and we'll do um should we go out there
on saturday
and do distribution of food or clothing
when we have the six days what should we
actually do on this sabbath as god
do we come that as good giving food is
good yes given our clothes is good of
course
but as you said or you suggested is it
possible to do it
on one of the days of the week
you see the sabbath must always be on
our minds it must
always be on our minds and by if when
that's the case it guides our choices
our decisions our behaviors on the six
days
am i conducting myself in such a way on
the six days that no
violence all is done to the sabbath can
it be done
for between sunday and friday and almost
always the answer is yes you know david
wanted to build the ark that's a good
thing not the art the attempt the temple
god said no let solomon do it so the
fact that something looks good doesn't
mean that you have to do it
we seek god's guidance can i restrict
this thing to the six days
one of our problems generally is that
our very
low view of the holiness of the sabbath
we have a
long view of the holiness of god's
sabbath
which is directly a result of our lord
view of the holiness of god
anything that can be done in the six
days
do it it may call for sacrifice it may
cause some inconvenience
but calvary was inconvenient but jesus
went through it
amen obedience is a form of sacrifice
all right elder skeet you let me know
when you want me to ask the last
question
all right let's hear this one uh this
question is if people need to take buses
to get to church
is a bus driver who knows about the
sabbath and chooses to
to work doing wrong is the person riding
the bus
doing wrong by paying for the bus
okay
let me express what i said earlier
our motive must be how can i obey
not is there a way to get around this
commandment the question how can i obey
how this is what must drive us how can i
too often our question is
how can i get around this thing and once
we have that mentality we will find ways
to get around
because the carnal nature will produce
them
christian church members you know elvis
says before christ come we will go back
to primitive godliness
so that if i know there's a member in my
area who needs a ride
i arrange to have that person picked the
church can make arrangements to have
people picked up but very often guys one
person doesn't care about the other once
i get to church that's my business you
find your way
a church family is a family one cares
about the other literally
that's why paul uses the body to refer
to the church if the tour is hurting
i am hurting if you shoot me in my oh
you have shot me
church members should come together what
can we do to ensure that people have
transportation
so they do not have because it's not
only a matter of paying the bus
it is a matter of being in an
environment that is not conducive for
sabbath keeping
you're hearing things you're seeing
things all of that must be considered
what can the church do well let me tell
you something when god's people come
together with the motivation what can we
do
to ensure that we obey god god makes a
way
but we must get away from well how can i
get around this and get around that we
must get away from that
what we do as a church family to make
sure
that church members get to church
without taking buses or trains
amen amen and and you know i there are
two more questions that i see
and i think you perhaps answered the
first
one saying is it okay to keep the
sabbath alone and forget the other nine
commandments
no you can't do that genuine obedience
is total submission to god
the bible says ecclesiastes 12 13 the
commandments of god are the whole duty
of man
so if you ignore nine you're ignoring a
major part of your duty
the whole duty of man is obedience to
god's law
by the power of christ you cannot pick
and choose
because either one disobey you show
disrespect for god
you know when feet breaks into your
house he doesn't have to break every
window he breaks one and he comes in
one broken window and the security of
your house is compromised
one broken commandment and you've
compromised the authority of god
in your own life god gave us 10 because
he wants ten
if he wanted nine he would be given nine
god is very precise god told neiman
through elijah dipped seven times if he
dipped six he would have gone home a
leper
he had to dip several god is precise
and serious and strict with god's strict
and love go together very well
thank you thank you all the skeet now
someone has asked um
what if you go to a job like if you work
for a senior home i guess this is like
for the medical field
those that work in that realm is it okay
for them to
work on sabbath but not take the pay for
it
you're not supposed to work on sales
and how many languages i should say that
we're not
supposed to work on sabbath now
being a medical doctor or nurse is not
the basis for working because you get
time and a half or double time
we have counsel from loi medical mission
uh medical ministry page 216 paragraph
two
if the doctor or the nurse has to go in
only do that which is necessary
to ease suffering that's what she says
reserve everything else for the next for
the next day or the next several days
only do what is necessary to ease
suffering which is consistent with it is
lawful to do good on the sabbath
and of course the money must be given to
the church
which very few people do so being a
doctor or nurse does not mean the
sabbath does not apply to you
because once you make an exemption for a
nurse or a doctor here comes the firemen
here comes the policeman here comes the
electrician here comes the pilot
here comes everybody well i need an
exemption
none of the 10 comes with an exemption
all right this next question says and
thank you for that
so should pastors not receive
honorariums for preaching on the sabbath
that's a very interesting question
should pastors not receive honorariums
from preaching on the sabbath
i've never heard that never thought of
it it was a very good question now the
bible says
the laborer is worthy of his reward but
if preaching is considered
work you see when an elder preaches is
that work
perhaps no now if a pastor is is hired
by a conference
he is already being paid by a conference
there is no need for him to be paid by a
church
to whom he goes to speak you understand
but
work whether it's preaching or whatever
it may be work
must be avoided on the sabbath but the
church has to be shepherded on the south
but if it applies to uh the conference
can very easily say we're paying you for
what you do between sunday and friday
we don't pay you for what you do on on
on the holy day
but we i still get back to the question
should a pastor
receive an honorarium for what he does
on sabbath
i've never heard that i'll have to think
about that never heard it
now if you consider preaching work
then he shouldn't work on sabbath
thank you for that no work is to be done
on sabbath
no work do good yes
no work no compensation for work on
sabbath
amen amen now this question and thank
you for that this question says my local
sda hospital organization
holds five k so five kilometer walks on
the sabbath
tied to different diseases
well it's a seventh-day adventist
hospital organization
they ho 5k walks the sabbath
i tell you god's people god's people
make me smile
why can't they hold it between sunday
and friday
leave god's sabbath alone
leave it alone keep
questionable activities for the week
if there's a question about it avoid it
you have
six days to walk 10 000 miles if you
choose
why do it on the sabbath
my policy is leave the sabbath alone
don't touch it you're not supposed to
touch the tide
don't touch it
let me just mute someone and then i will
allow
okay dr terra long i see you would like
to pose your question you are free to do
so
and pastor skeet i have a follow-up
question to the wand of broken and
sabbath
yes if all the nurses don't go to work
and suffer because it is work
who who will take care of the patients
now you're looking at it you're looking
at obedience from man's point of view
not from god
if god calls you to obey him he will
deal with consequences
we must never look at this thing from
the perspective of people even though
people are involved
but we must always begin from the side
of god
the bible tells us it's lawful to do
good on the sabbath yesterday is
suffering yes
our prophet tells us only do that which
is necessary to ease suffering
and leave the rest you see when we when
we go and apply for jobs we must tell
employers very clearly who we are and
what we stand for
very often we don't because if we do we
may endanger possible employment
our employers must know right up front
this is what i do this is what i don't
do because i'm a
seventh-day adventist
and so if you're a nurse or doctor
whatever you are
god bless that profession luke was a
medical doctor
but it does not change the fourth
commandment
in it thou shalt not do any work
again alawite tells us do good
do good but leave unnecessary work for
other day
honor god's law
this is no joke total obedience to god
is not as widespread as some of us may
think there's no such thing as
convenient obedience
the highest expression of obedience is
calvary
that's what the bible says he became
obedient unto death even the death of
the cross
genuine obedience includes sacrifice
amen amen this is very sick i'm glad
we're having this discussion
one of the reasons before the power of
god is because we don't obey god
amen thank you for that elder skeet now
this next question
kind of speaks to the one about the
honorariums it says
is it okay to pay singers or musicians
to play or sing
in church on the sabbath well if it's
wage earning
it's work
it's work in it thou shalt not do any
work
amen amen you see we
there must be principles on which we
stand one principle is
you cannot make an exemption for any one
of the ten commandments
you cannot do that once you do that
you open the floodgates to make
exemptions for all the other nine
so some man can argue well i live in a
country where they
uh ten times as many women as men so i'm
helping out society by having five wives
no no no no no we
cannot make exemptions for any one of
the ten
amen amen